Boobs.
They’re complicated, and they’re also
cannibals.
Well, sort of…
Hey mammary-gland mavens, Julian here for
DNews.
So we all know that after women give birth,
their breasts swell to become milk machines
for their newborns.
But biologists have long tried to explain
how, when a woman stops producing milk for
breastfeeding, the breasts shrink back to
normal size in a matter of days.
New research gives us some answers – they
effectively “eat” themselves to regenerate.
According to a September 2016 study in the
journal Developmental Cell, when a woman is
done lactating, certain cells in her breast
consume other dead neighboring cells, which
are left over from the breastfeeding process.
In other words, the breast’s cells turn
on each other and become cannibals!
Whoa!
Before we go into the details, we have to
know more about how breasts work.
Breasts are made up of a network of ducts,
surrounded by a layer of fatty tissue.
When a woman is pregnant, hormones increase
the number of epithelial cells that line these
ducts.
Epithelial cells line our skin, digestive
tract and other internal organs, acting as
a barrier between our bodies and contaminants
in the environment; and depending on where
they are in the body, they can perform different
functions -- like allowing us to taste, touch
and smell, or secreting mucus to process nutrients.
When these cells increase in the breast ducts,
they form alveoli, tiny sacs that hold the
milk.
But when a woman stops breastfeeding, the
sacs self-destruct and become debris that
needs to be removed.
And they do so with the help of a Pac-Man-like
protein called Rac1.
Normally, the body’s immune cells get rid
of foreign matter in a different way – a
process called phagocytosis.
This complex series of steps allows immune
cells called phagocytes to identify dead and
dying cells and destroy them, which causes
inflammation, pain and tissue damage.
But women who finish breastfeeding don’t
typically experience the pain associated with
this process– so scientists surmised that
something else must be responsible for the
clean-up of dead cells.
They singled out the protein Rac1, which plays
a key role in both milk production and phagocytosis.
To investigate, they bred a litter of mice
that couldn’t produce the protein.
Then those mice reproduced.
Turns out, most of their pups didn’t survive
because their mice mothers stopped being able
to produce milk for them.
The lack of Rac1 caused a buildup of dead
cells, which blocked normal milk production.
Excess milk then accumulated in the breast
tissue, which became inflamed and swollen.
This showed that Rac1 is crucial for getting
rid of dead cells and preventing harmful inflammatory
responses.
It also seemingly keeps dead cells attached
to the alveoli for longer, encouraging the
epithelial cells to eat each other.
It’s possible that this cell-eating-cell
process happens in other organs, since epithelial
cells form the building blocks of our bodies.
Scientists in the same study noted that it
is thought humans shed the equivalent of their
own body weight in dead cells every year.
If phagocytosis were solely responsible, we’d
be constantly inflamed... so maybe this cannibalization
is happening all over your body.
The findings could also provide more insight
into the development and progression of breast
cancer, since lingering dead cells and resulting
inflammation could allow cancer cells to grow.
After all, women have an increased risk of
breast cancer in the first five to ten years
following pregnancy and a whopping 80-90 percent
of all cancers come from epithelial cells.
While further research is needed, Rac1 may
have a crucial role in the development of
anticancer therapies.
So there you have it – a woman’s body
heals itself by eating itself in a bizarre
form of regeneration.
Consider yourself now a little less confused
about women.
And if you want to know more about breast
milk and maybe if it could be used as a sports
drink substitute, I have a video on that right
over here.
So, do you have any other questions about
some weird stuff the body does you want us
to look into?
Go ahead and let us know in the comments,
subscribe for more and I will see you all
next time on DNews.